mes chers amis nous sommes la droite
nous sommes les héritiers du général de
Gaulle vous êtes ces militants courageux
toujours vaillants comme moi vous voulez
plus d'autorité car le respect manque
dans notre société nos lois sont
bafouées nos frontières violées nos
policiers gendarmes pompiers enseignants
élus sont attaqués nos traditions sont
malmenées nos modes de vie sont remises
en cause je veux rétablir l'ordre
partout et pour tous je veux vous donner
la liberté d'agir ceux qui travaillent
doivent gagner plus que ceux qui vivent
de l'assistanat ceux qui ont travaillé
durent toute leur vie doivent être
protégées nous devons être le parti de
la baisse des impôts de la diminution
des normes de l'effacement de la
bureaucratie mes amis que la France est
belle sublime éternelle résistante
résiliente nous devons protéger ses
racines sa culture son patrimoine nous
ne pouvons pas la laisser aux mains des
idéologues rockistes des islamistes de
ceux qui l'habillent à coups de béton
d'éoliennes demain avec vous avec la
droite au coeur je veux me battre pour
cette France que nous aimons
passionnément et que nous voulons voir
grande belle et respecter